超光速下单
全方位克服
行情一把抓
交易猛如虎
开场先念个定场诗
然后
是吧 有看过戏吧
都是这样子
最怕是有加钱的吗
没有 没有加钱
刚看了影片把他的几句抓起来
当定场诗
然后就是
就是
交易期货的新手就是
你可以上网一直查规则
然后也可以找一个营业员
然后不停地问他各式各样的规则
那基本上
就是
了解交易规则是非常重要的
其实不管玩什么游戏就是
或做任何事情
了解规则都是非常重要
像我刚刚在演讲前
我就特别问了营业员妹妹
就是
讲者现在是不需要戴口罩
哦
我们了解规则
好不好
因为我很不喜欢戴口罩
真的很热
好
我们刚刚讲到这一页吗
对
好
utility就是
效用快乐值爽度
好
就是
就是这样
因为我们人生就是要最大化的追求
现在的utility和未来的utility
那当然未来的utility的价值会
稍微受到这个权重的降低
当然现在的快乐还是比较重要的
好我们可以往下了
好这个就是dimension marginal utility
下面是钱
这边是效用
然后你的钱一直增加
你的快乐只增加一点点
然后会增加的越来越慢
对于穷人来说
这个增加了10万美金的财富
可以让原本没钱的人改变一生
好
但是这个
对于川普来说
这个秘书打电话来说
哎你川普你这个
中彩票发票中了10万美金啊
哇那绝对是被川普骂的狗血淋头
10万块还要打电话来浪费我的时间
一秒钟几十万上下的好吗
好可以再往下
然后就是展望理论
人对于损失比获得更加敏感
好这个是一系列这个理论发展的过程
一开始觉得人衡量的是这个
钱的数字
然后后来觉得人衡量的是期望值
然后最后我们发现人衡量的是一个展望
就是我们
对损失会比对获得更加敏感
好可以看下一张
这个价值函数就是
这边一样X轴是钱
Y轴是utility就是快乐
那
获得我们得到的快乐
是这样子
那一样这个
这个一样是concave up
凹口向上的就是
他是这样子
就是你越亏越多钱
你后面也会比较没有感觉
越赚越多钱后面比较没有感觉
但是可以看出来就是
获得得到的快乐是比较低的
损失造成的不快乐是比较高的
就是损失造成的不快乐是比较高的
就是损失100美元的痛苦这么长
得到100美元的痛苦这么短
所以对于大部分普通人来说
你如果要跟他丢硬币
你就随便找一个人
我们玩一个公平的丢硬币
猜人头还是数字
一次100美元就是3000台币
要不要来读一下
大部分人都会不愿意参与这个赌局
因为他们是用这么大的不快乐
去换取这么短的快乐
是吧?我们来做一个小互动好了
如果就是待会后面的赌场
你会在这一块钱的赌场
待会后面可以参加一次3000台币的丢硬币
等一下可以来前台跟我来赌个丢硬币
待会开放10个名额一次3000块
就猜人头还是钱币
会觉得太棒了
这个游戏一定要参加的举手
只有一个人
可以跟马克兰玩游戏耶
就是那么少人
好吧
那觉得说
我肯定不会参加这个游戏的丢硬币
可以加一点吗
赢到3000一输了3000
没有
我们就是要
就是比较一下嘛
因为说不定
多了3%就会那个嘛
不一样
好吧
看起来好很多人就是大家都不喜欢举手
哈哈哈
好我们实验结果就是大家都不喜欢举手
好
要玩跟不玩的人都很少
可以看下一页
好那这个是说
人会太短的停力跟太长的停损
如果我原本设定的是200块停力跟100块停损
但是行情走到正100的时候
我预设是200块停力
可是
我觉得
在
100块的获利
可以增加快乐只有这么高
但是
回挡到0的话
我损失的快乐是这么多
所以我就决定提早停力
因为
再加100块钱
增加快乐这么少
可是回挡造成的痛苦这么大
所以
人就会提早停力
就比你设定的更早停力
然后这边是停损
你设定-100停损
但是到-100的时候你觉得
到-100的时候你觉得
如果可以回到0的话
诶
这么大的一段快乐被吸回去
不快乐
他是负的快乐
被弄回去了
但是到这边的话只增加这一段不快乐
那就不停损啊
我就赌会不会回到-100
但是因为这样是逆势嘛
所以其实是比较容易多亏钱
就是这个几率会比这个更大
那你到-100的时候到200的机会
到200的机会会比回到0更大
因为这个是顺势嘛
这边是逆势嘛
好大家应该都听得懂吧
讲得太好
收益增加快乐的放大不多
损失增加痛苦的放大也很少
所以人性会导致没有受过训练的交易者
注定都会赔钱
就是停利会更早
然后停损会更快
然后而且就是交易这件事情
不是一个适合用经验学习的事情
因为就是错误的经验会加强你进行错误的行为
而且你很有可能就会自己调整成这个
长停损短停利
那在经验上你就会常常一直赚一点
赚一点赚一点
所以你累积起来那个快乐是很高的
而且经验也会告诉你
这样的话就常常会赚赚赚赚赚赚
连续赚很多天
但是一天就会直接把你前面赚的全部都赔回去
所以交易是不适合用经验来累积
就是如果一个人交易了十几年
但是他也输了十几年的钱
那他就应该完全停止他的交易
就是因为他完全没有学到正确的方式
而且是持续用错误的方式在送大家钱
所以交易是一个需要用数学和人性来做的东西
不要用经验来学习交易
好可以往下了
然后人性让人自然而然太早停损
太早停利跟太晚停损
那就是上面那些数学的东西
就是行为经济学
行为经济学就是要让你知道人会犯什么错
人为什么会犯这些错
然后自己避免犯这些错
然后利用别人犯的错而收取他的价值
例如说别人不停损
那因为根据规则交易的规则
在什么时候他会被券商强迫的停损
或者是断头或者是怎样
那而造成行情的反转
那例如说崩盘策略
你可能就可以估计这个跌了700点的时候
这个他的开盘就买多单的交易者
他的保证金会到剩25%
然后所以那个地方可能就会有一波
这个大家一起被断头
然后行情就有一个小的反转
那像这些都是这个抓取对方可能会做的事情
来收取价值的方法
然后更高的数学程度
让你更快做更高观点的判断
像刚刚说那个concave up,concave down
然后可以往下
好,然后这个是
就是之前说的嘛
短停例就是更短的
持有正确的仓位
那这个是跟正确的方式完全相反的
但是大部分人的人性都会让你做
跟正确的事情相反的事情
然后这个很重要
就是非常非常多的交财经的人
因为事实上大部分交财经的人
他们自己都没有在交易
或者是他们自己的交易也是赔钱的
或者是说他们都是在大多头的时候
这个买入无限量的0050跟台积电
然后永远不停损
那反正股市一直在涨的时候
他们就觉得自己的方法真好
因为股市一直在涨
所以台积电是个好公司
还好我看到了好公司
那就一直往上
然后呢
但是他们自己交的那些这个
没什么用的课就是交
如果本益比很低
如果值利率很高
出现了就买这个股票
但是其实股价一直在上涨的时候
本益比是会提高的
值利率也是会下降的
那什么时候会出现低本益比跟高值利率呢
就是股价一直在下跌的时候
本益比就是股价除以EPS
然后所以股价如果一直下跌的时候
本益比就会一直下降
那例如说可能有人就说什么
台股的平均本益比是20
那出现了10以下的本益比就
这个开始买入
那但是都是在股价一直持续下跌
本益比从20跌到10的时候它买入
那它就买到了一个已经下跌很长一段的股票
那它就是非常逆势的在买股票
那高值利率也是一样
就是长隆从这个158块的时候公布出全息
那当时的本益值利率应该是10出头
那到108块出息的时候
或是120块的时候
那值利率又是大幅的提升
那如果因此而增加了买入的意愿的话
那就是超级逆势
逆势到不行
所以
出现低本益比出现高值利率
而买入股票是一件愚蠢到不行的事情
然后
好所以不要这样子买股票
不然你会买到正在下跌的股票
好就是反正我讲的这些
其实跟市场上的很多那些教学都是讲完全相反的
那但是就是大家都可以看出来在股市一直下跌的时候
或是在震荡的时候就会知道符合数学才是正确的方式
就是多的时候确实买多
但是跌的时候你应该要猜往下
而不是无论如何都猜往上
好
然后
这个上一次讲过的策略
但是这个策略真的很重要
所以再讲一次
就是呢
你可以
选择10党
这一个季节
或这个半年或这一年你要买的股票
然后
赔钱的股票就把它卖掉
换成去买正在赚钱的那些股票
那所以你的持股清单可能就从10党慢慢减少
因为赔钱的股票被你卖掉了
然后最后都换成赚钱的股票
因为他们更有可能持续上涨
那当然还是会有一些策略的细节
然后最后如果所有的股票都在下跌
那就把所有股票都卖掉
好
然后就是
猶豫和害怕输钱会让你输更多钱
就是
要正确的执行你的策略
如果你的策略是在这个地方进场
那你就在那个地方进场
那你已经管进场了
你就不是进场在趋势开始反转之后
就是观察到趋势反转之后
就马上进场
那如果已经又走了一段的话
那你的成本可能就会比别人差一些
然后因为这个扛勤开始反转之后
停损就可以守在最低点嘛
那又走了一段
那你的停损就又更长
那你又需要更长的停力
来cover这样的停损
所以就是
怕输钱会让你输更多钱
好
然后
猶豫会让你输更多钱
停损会让你赚更多钱
好
这个停损怎么会赚钱呢
是这样
就是
你如果买入一个15300的多单
然后我的日盘主要策略都是10点停损
10点15290的时候停损
就是行情
在
又跌到15200的时候
然后这时候我们重新买入多单
那
这个另外一个是15300的时候
买入
比如说一半数量的多单
或者这个是它的两倍数量的多单
然后
它不停损
往下一百点再探评一次
15200多单探评
那
在15200的时候
它就已经损失了100点了
然后
在这边的话
它是两倍嘛
所以是损失了10点的两倍
那所以
在一开始到15200的时候
它就已经赢它了
然后行情回到15250的时候
那
它是已经开始获利了嘛
已经获利40点的两倍
就是80点了
那
这边的
这个还回到
才刚回到成本
平均的成本
所以就是
短停损
那我是懒得列
就是怎么停损两次
然后它摊平两次
都是一样的效果
就是
短停损
重新进场
更好的成本
那行情
因为
它在赌的事情就是
行情回来的时候
我都把它卖掉嘛
对吧
所以它才一直无限往下摊平
那跟这个不一样
这个是
行情回来的时候
我就已经赚钱了
所以
停损
就会让你赚更多的钱
好
就是
持续的短停损
你可以停损很多次
那另外一个点是
这两种单种
谁更可能可以继续抱得住多单
应该是这一边
因为唐秦回到15250的时候
它是已经有获利了
所以它更能够继续持有它的多单
那这边的话是它摊平
然后从-100点回到打平变0了
那像这种就是不太知道数学怎么使用的人
就是根本没在使用数学的人
它更有可能回到15250
赶快就把多单平掉了
哎
截套了截套了
或是赚个五点
截套了
就是卖掉
好
所以这就是停损会让你赚更多钱
短停损
然后更好的成本重新进场
好
就是我突然想到
有人密我说
这个
他希望他可以学我的交易方法
然后每天赢个三点到五点就好了
那200块乘200块是600到1000块
每天赢个三到五点
就是没有这种策略好吗
三到五点停利
那你要几点停损
一点就停损吗
哈哈哈哈
就没有这样
就这个策略
就是会问这个问题的人
他显然是完全搞不清楚游戏规则
好不好
就是
好
我只是突然想到这个故事而已
为什么我们一定要学习行为经济学
因为行为经济学更符合
现实世界的人类的样子
现实世界的人类就是
不理性
然后
这个
因为情绪而做决定
然后不会数学
非常愚蠢
好
我也顺便讲一下这个
就是人类做决定
只跟两件事情有关
第一个是思考的习惯
第二个是当下接收到的刺激
就是人类做决定
只跟这两件事有关
那思考的习惯就是
你过去经历过的所有事情
在你脑中形成的
这些神经突出跟电流
那这些神经突出电流
就像是这个山上水流下来的那些沟渠水道一样
就是你不停的用一样的方式思考
就像是这个山上
就是天上滴下来的那个水
一直不停的划过一样的一道小溪流
那那个小溪流就可能会越来越深
越来越宽
以后水滴下来的时候
就更有可能从一样的地方
继续流下去
那这就会形成你思考的习惯
那这就是
我们物理学上很常把电流比喻成水流
其实还是有一定程度的相似性
那所以这个思考的习惯
跟当下接受到自己
也就是水滴在哪里
然后你已经形成那些沟渠
会往哪边流
那所以如果是一对一的支配数的话
就是你要去观察和了解
你面前的这个人
这个人他思考的习惯是什么
他是属于哪一个类型的人格个性
他思考的方式是属于什么类型
他能够接收到你什么样程度的刺激
你讲的什么语言他更能接受
他更不会听不懂
然后你给予对应的刺激
来让他做出你希望他做出的决定
那这是一对一的支配数
那这也是就是我们了解人思考的方式啊
好
然后我们继续往下看吧
好那就是传统经济学
就是以前课本上学到那些就是
什么假设什么供需曲线
然后所以我们厂商就会把价格定在这个供需曲线的交叉点
但是经济学家就打电话问了非常非常多这个首屈指的那些大型销售企业
问他们是不是看画出了供需曲线
然后在焦点上面定价的
当然得出来的结果就是没有任何一家企业是这样定价的
首先是供需曲线很可能画不出来
然后而且实际上他定价的方式应该是考量消费者愿意服夺
然后还有市场上其他的价这个是定多少的定价
然后还有怎么定价会让消费者觉得他减到便宜了
好可以继续往下
好所以传统经济学是我们假设大家会做出最好的决定
但是显然不是这样
然后好这上次讲过了
可以往下
好人理性吗市场是对的吗
就是人是不会数学也不会做出正确决定的
然后市场上就是由这样的一群愚蠢的人类组成
那所以大家都会一起做出错误的决定
那如果你可以做出更接近数学上正确的决定的话
你就更有可能击败这个市场
好市场由一群不理性的存淡人类组成
好就是不停损的当初就是说就是很多很多的交易者都不停损啊
所以就是可以研究交易规则
例如说他是在通常什么时候融资会同时被断头
什么时候这个就是期货的当冲者会同时被断头
或者说被强制回补啦
就例如说围盘当冲保证金减半会强制回补啊
然后融资通常在第二天9点多的时候会被断头啊
那这些都是可以观察第一融资维持维持绿的股票
就是会不会在那个时候出现一个断头的贩转行情
因为空单被断头就是多单的买入回补嘛
好然后这个是大涨大铁盘常常会收在当天最高最低点
然后不停损的当冲客最后又要再多支付一次这个价值这样
好所以知道别人会做什么
就会可以用策略让别人支付你
好例如说这个发行反向ETF的法人
需要在最后几天去主动的换仓下个月的这个空单
那也有可能会造成远月跟近月价差扩大
那这个也是一个非常非常好的
让这个出反向ETF的法人支付你的方法
那所以基本上去买反向ETF都是一个非常非常不好的决定
就是你要买反向ETF的话
你就自己去买入小台的空单就可以了
好
然后one ahead principle就是永远领先对手一步
不管是魔术、独心术、股市都是一样
你永远领先对手一步
你就可以得到更好的结果
好那魔术的话就是出其不意嘛
因为别人想不到你已经做了留一手的一件事情
然后独心术建立在强大的同理心跟博学多文上
就是
好可以看下一张
就是独心术建立的是博学多文
而且你有很强大的同理心
那就像富尔摩斯嘛
他可以看别人走路的方式
然后加上他的博学多文
他可以判断出来
走来的这个人是一个水手
然后他这个
因为水手走路的方式是怎样
或者是他以前是一个间谍
因为他走路的时候
手只有一边在摆
另外一边是准备拔枪的一些
就是这个
俄罗斯的普丁就是这样一个特殊的
这个走路方式嘛
因为他以前是KGB
所以就走路就摆一边
因为这边随时准备拔枪
那就是
反正就是你对这个世界的了解越多
你越有可能可以正确的判断
别人是什么样类型的人
别人是怎么样思考的
然后你可以观察到更多东西
所以不是像贝卡斯一样
或者是像电影里面一样
就是你被闪电电到
然后可以听到别人的声音
独心术不是这样
好
可以往下
这个
上一次二月的讲座
没有讲独心术的故事
今天
这个同一张投影片终于有时间讲了
好
就是我们让
这个
因为上一次有
这个小妹妹来后面
她可能完全听不懂期货
但是呢我们讲一个这个听不懂期货的人也能听得懂的故事
然后又跟心理学有关
这样至少大家会记得今天听了一些事情
好
这个
这个独心术就是也能帮助大家了解独心术大概是什么样子啊
就是呢
我以前是补习班老师
然后我们有LINE群组
就是里面有很多的家长跟学生
然后这些家长跟学生
就是大部分互相不太认识
就是一个LINE群组里面会有接近500个人
那在群组里面就是会宣布一些跟这个补习班有关的事情嘛
那这个例如说我们就会公布今天这个没有请假也没有来上课的同学名单
那这样家长就会知道小朋友今天没有请假又没有来上课
是不是跑去网卡打电动啊
还是
还是就是干嘛
还是躲在图书馆读书啊
对不对
都有可能
那我们公布就是例如说
如果是名字三个字的话
就会让中间那个字
这个变成一个圈
就是保护各自嘛
乘圈语
然后是马圈九
这样子
中间那个字是一个圈
然后
就是有一次有一个同学
他叫做这个陈冠豪
那他就被助教公布在今天没有来上课也没有请假的名单里面
今天没有来的是陈圈匾
然后陈圈豪
就是可能后面还有几个名字这样
可能五六个人今天没有来
然后陈冠豪他就传讯息密助教说
你助教你记错了
那个我今天有请假
我确实没来
但是我有
我有跟一个助教讲过请假
那个上面怎么会有我的名字
那我看到这边我就知道
就是他就爆狼
就是他就聊暴了
他就是他肯定就是没有来也没有请假
那不然的话他不会跟助教讲这个话
我再重讲一次好了
陈冠豪看到陈圈豪的名字之后跟助教说
上面怎么有我的名字
我有请假
有人大概可以感受出来
这是一件很奇怪的事情吗
因为陈冠豪是一个菜市场名
也就是说如果你是陈冠豪的话
你会非常的习惯
在各种各样的榜单上面
常常出现陈圈豪但那个人不是你
可能是陈家豪可能是陈智豪
可能是陈天豪就是类似的名字
所以在一个五百人的群组
然后大家互相不认识
你应该密助教会先问他说
诶那个陈圈匾下面的陈圈豪是在说我吗
而不是说怎么上面有我的名字
他认为那个是他就爆了
这就是读心书
就是你要换位思考站在别人的角度
去思考他应该正确的视角是怎么思考问题的
如果他叫做陈冠豪
那他就是一个菜市场名字的人
他就会有一个世界观
我是菜市场名字
榜单上名单上常常会出现我的名字
所以那个人就不是我
那你就算自己不是菜市场名
你也要能够同理菜市场名的人的感受
那这个故事就更有可能讲到一半的时候
你的名字是一个常见名字的人
你更能够知道
啊他爆狼了
他怎么没想到那个人很可能不是他
这个就是同理型
如果你的名字越常见
你越有可能听到一半的时候就知道
他讲错了
他这个真的是不太行
好
这是上一次没讲的
读心术的故事
好
然后
这个人们对于觉得损失的感受
高于实际的得失
就是我们上一次画的那个嘛
就是
好
我们上一次讲了就是另外一个
就是人打疫苗跟就是进实验室的
就是人不知道怎么样衡量一个东西价值
那我们再讲另外一个人不知道怎么衡量
事物价值的故事好了
就是这个
好
这个可以跟大家小互动一下
就是
想像你现在是在这个沙滩上面度假
然后
这个
就是晒个日光雨
然后你希望现在可以喝到一杯
沁凉的这个啤酒
那我们就固定个品牌好了
我们在台湾就讲
一瓶沁凉的台湾啤酒
没有业配就是固定品牌的一瓶600cc的台湾啤酒
然后你在这个好我们就固定好我们在外澳的这个沙滩上面躺在那边赛日光雨
那如果你请你的朋友去旁边的7-11
或者是旁边的一家小杂货店
帮你买一杯这个600cc的台湾啤酒的话
你最高可以接受那个杂货店卖多少钱
你还是会买这一杯台湾啤酒
来
有没有人要取手
这个我们可以送一个
送个小笔记本跟便条纸
太好了送便条纸
没有涵盖很笔记本然后便条纸还有原子笔
哇塞我要回答
50块
后面还有大理
现在这个就是
我可以拿吗
好
50块
我会愿意在杂货店愿意花50块买这杯台湾啤酒
就是略高于市价嘛
人家杂货店做生意也是要一点钱嘛
然后第二个是一样的情境
就是躺在外澳的沙滩上
然后我要去这个旁边的这个五星级大饭店
请朋友买一杯一样600cc的台湾啤酒
那跟在便利商店买到的台湾啤酒
都是一样的品质
然后干净卫生程度
然后产品是完全一样的
你能够躺在沙滩上享用得到的服务也没有任何不同
就是喝到同样一杯台湾啤酒
如果就是失去五星级大饭店
请朋友帮你买的话
你们最多愿意支付多少钱
我可以再拿一本吗
我已经回答两题了
这个就是把握机会
我已经两本了
好
那这个故事告诉我们什么呢
就是人其实不知道怎么样衡量一个事情的价值
就是你都是一样在沙滩上享用到完全一样的同一杯台湾啤酒
但是你会因为你内心觉得它是杂货店买的
所以你愿意买入的最高价值就只有50块
那因为是五星级饭店买的
你愿意买入的最高价就是150块
那这个故事听起来也不会不合理嘛
50跟150也都还算是合理
但是在传统经济学里面
这就是一件非常不合理的事情
因为我们要不要买一个东西的衡量
应该是我会衡量这一杯啤酒
带给我的快乐的价值换算成钱大概是70块
那50块的杂货店我就会买
150块的我就不会买
不会有我享受到一样的服务
但是是在更好的店我就愿意支付更高的价钱
这样的事情
大家应该都听得懂意思吧
好
这就是人其实不知道怎么样衡量一件事情的价值
就跟传统经济学里面
就是那个画什么工区曲线啊什么
那个就是显然不是现实世界人类的思考方式
好
然后再来就是人会过度的在意这样感觉心里不爽
然后人会非常的在意买这个东西
是不是觉得他变便宜了
这就是建议售价的力量
就是你如果买的东西建议售价是100块
但是他卖你95块的话
赚到5块好爽
建议售价100卖80
赚20块
建议售价2万卖80
你就会发现你被骗了
所以通常不会这样子定
所以这个是很重要的喔
建议售价不能够偏离原本的价钱太多
因为你会发现他只是在唬烂你
这个很重要就是
你要让他觉得中间的那个价差真的是你赚到的
而且他不是在唬烂你
那这个在
这个在美国的这个
潘尼百货跟
在美西百货都有
就是佩妮跟梅西都有出现过
就是当时的这个百货公司新的经营者
他觉得就是我的每一个东西都是什么
什么99.99
什么什么跟什么
就是为什么不就10块呢
然后弄一大堆莫名其妙的折价券
然后建议售价跟实际售价都不一样
他把这些全部都取消
9.99全部都改成卖10块
然后也不用折价券了
我就是要卖你10块的
你也不需要用12块
然后再用折价券折成10块
然后也不用建议售价
12块然后卖9.99
结果那个潘尼跟梅西百货的销售量跟股价
都遭受到非常严重的重挫
那因为人想要买的是那一个买到便宜的划算的感觉
有时候我们都不是要买那件衣服
我们要买的是双11的折扣
就我今天老公我今天不是上网买了5000块的衣服
我是上网买了500块的折扣啊
我是在赚钱啊老公
对吧
是不是很多人心里应该都是这样想的
那后来这个潘尼跟梅西百货他们又重新恢复
因为发现销售量实在是下跌太多了
又重新恢复了原本的那些建议售价折价券
但是在后来的三到五年内
他们的这个销售量也没有重新回升
因为人们发现原来你原本就是要卖我10块
原来建议售价是骗人的啊
就他们发现你是在骗他这件事情
就造成他没有因为你花12块卖10块
而觉得赚到那2块爽感的感觉
大家懂那个意思吧
所以建议售价不能订2万然后卖80
要订100卖80
你才会觉得赚到那20块
那2万的话你只会赚到那20块
那2万的话你只会觉得拍个照上传限动
这个是不是硬错了
对吧
好那可以往下看
好然后不愿意买回的正确仓位
就是沉没成本啦
就是如果你是这个正确的仓位
然后重新买回同样的方向
但是成本在不好的地方
在比刚刚出厂的地方更差的地方
但是你现在重新进厂是正EV的
有些人就会不愿意重新买回
但是其实就是你每一个做的新的动作都是正EV的就可以了
然后就是我们不是要尽量逃离负面情绪
尽量让自己交易的很爽
我们应该是尽量的长期稳定的赚钱
然后所以就是我们要依照数学逻辑交易
不要跟着盘感交易
好然后沉没成本上次也讲过了
就是沉没成本就是你现在做的决定不会改变的过去已经发生的成本
就例如说这个你交一个
这个男朋友好了
好像讲分手女朋友都觉得很坏
你讲分手男朋友大家就觉得还好
对不对
你交一个男朋友
然后那个男朋友
这个就是反正就很不好嘛
就是我也不知道怎样很不好这个
好像不管怎么讲都会
都会得罪一些人什么又矮又穷又丑
然后就有些人就觉得什么啊胖子就错了嘛
成圈宇是不是
哈哈哈哈哈哈
好反正就是不好就对了
你交了一个不好的男朋友
然后那过去你在他身上花的时间就是沉没成本嘛
那如果接下来你再继续跟他在一起一年
对你造成的是不快乐而不是更多的快乐的话
那你就不要因为已经跟他交往了五年
所以不愿意跟他分手
因为舍不得就是浪费了之前的时间
然后就继续跟增加你的不快乐
跟一个不快乐的男人在一起
所以女人要独立
好没有就得出一个没用的结论
忽略沉没成本抛开不舍
做出当下最正确的决定
好吧就是交易者或是理性者
都比较能够做出正确的决定
就是比较能够断去以前的
像是例如说我当医生可能一个月
还是稳稳的可以赚个三四十万
那但是这个我的快乐没有做其他的事情更高
那我就可以
好那就不用当医生了
那就是以前花的时间就是我的沉默成本
然后我就再继续往前下一个决定
好赌徒心理就是我们在大赚跟大赔的时候
都有可能会让因为情绪
而让你自己做出偏离策略的举动
就是你赚了很多的时候你可能就想说
反正现在这单就随便再下一下
就是好像也没有很符合策略
但是好像有符合策略的五个条件里面的两个
好啦读一下啦
反正大不了就把今天赚了二十万赔回去
那这样的话你就是在做一个负EV的决定
那另外一个可能性就是
你今天已经赔了二十万
然后你就觉得五个条件里面
也符合两个人
我今天很想赶快尻回来
你就加大筑马直接下筑四十万
希望就是把那二十万给打回来
然后根本就没有符合你原本在执行的策略
所以你一定要注意自己
有没有开始偏离你的策略
或是开始偏离你平常下筑的尺度
如果有的话你就有可能因为
就是最近期的行情的赚赔而产生
而产生就是上头啦
on tilt 倾斜了
就不平衡了
那所以一定要观察自己
就是如果你发现你输钱
就开始加大你下筑的尺码
或者是开始没有符合交
那个进场条件就开始进场
或是你出场条件也不符合
那你就要知道你今天就完全暂停交易
你就马上离场
然后今天就不要再继续交易了
那因为要控制自己不要上头
几乎是不可能的事情
就是每个人都有一个会上头的尺度
那要么你就规定自己连续停损几次
就不继续下筑
那不然就是观察自己
怎样的情况的话
就应该完全暂时离开市场
冷静一下
好
然后输钱或赢钱的情绪
都可能让人过度冲动
过度保守
然后一定要观察自己
就是
然后还有另外一个
不要一直在意你今天赚的那个钱
是要凑整数
就例如说
今天你赚了9300块
然后你很希望今天可以赚超过1万块
那我就
好像也没看到什么符合策略条件的
可是快要收盘了
算了
我再下注一个700块尺码的
好了
看能不能今天凑个赚1万块
心里也觉得爽
那有可能你就会
因此而蒙受更大的损失
就是
应该我们都是用
编辑Marginal
来思考这些事情
就是你做的这个新的决定
是不是一个正期望值的事情
就不要为了什么凑整
然后改变你的交易策略
不要为了
什么把今天输的给尻回来
目前这个损益是在
负35块
不行
那这样今天赔钱
我下个50块的
看能不能今天
赔回这个正15块
这个都是非常非常多人
心里很有可能会做的事情
就是实际上可能会做的事情
那这些都应该要避免
好
然后就不要在不理智的时候
下单
然后下单的原因也不要是因为
什么损益金额
什么
负一点点弄回正一点点
或者是什么
这个差了几点的数字
然后给它弄回来
然后建议一天连续输两笔单
就停止下单
那如果你的情绪控管更好一点
就是连续输三笔单
停止下单
那当然你可以自己抓
不一定要是两笔三笔
但是
但是一定是要
你真的能够控制自己
在不会on-thirt
不会上投的情况
持续下单
好
这个就是
刚刚讲的
交易效用跟消费者胜誉
这个consumer就是消费者
service胜誉
就是在传统经济学里面
这个
他觉得
人事衡量
这一杯啤酒
对我的快乐
utility
产生70元
价值70元的utility
然后呢
这个啤酒只卖50元
所以
我就赚到了
20元的消费者剩余
这个20就是
我赚到的
consumer surplus
我的utility
但是不可能有人是
这样子衡量事情的嘛
太扯了
那实际上我们
就是感受到的是交易效用
就是我是不是捡到便宜了
像是这个
我非常喜欢喝可口可乐
这个可口可乐
也不是业培
就是我真的喜欢喝
然后
这个可口可乐
就
从之前的29块
变成现在的35块
在便宜超商
那我感受到的就是
我每次买的时候
我都觉得我亏6块
而且就是6块哦
就是
我现在我每次买的时候
我都觉得我亏6块
因为我以前每天买都是29
现在买变35块
所以我感受到的就是
亏6块
那这起来是一个
非常愚蠢的事情嘛
就是
为什么我买那可乐
我可以算的那么准
就是我买那可乐
就是亏6块
因为
我心里面被anchor
就锚定那个
那个可乐的价值就是29块
那它卖35块
那也没办法嘛
就是还是得买
好
可以
哦好
然后
就是我们交易
就是要了解交易规则嘛
然后了解交易规则
就更可能可以发现
交易规则的漏洞
然后或者是别人
教了你一个错误的策略的时候
你很有可能可以知道
这个交易策略是有问题的
然后或者是
你更有机会
就是制定一个好的交易策略
那像是
我觉得我就是蛮擅长
这个
就发现交易规则的一些
巧门漏洞
然后或者是
如果交易规则是怎样的话
是不是就有可能有什么漏洞
所以我是非常非常常打电话
问营业员问题的
因为我会觉得
如果是这样的话
是不是就会有一个洞
那如果不是这样
那就是没有漏洞
这样
然后我也会想要了解
例如说
实际上它在执行
期货的低于25%断头
或者是融资低于维持率太低断头
那实际上你们是
这个AI断头还是人工断头
是怎么样子进行断头的
那如果你断头的话
你会先砍掉什么
这个人的什么仓位
是全部一起砍掉
还是从什么部位优先开始砍
那这样你都更能够理解
这些做了错误事情的人
他们身上会发生什么事情
那这些人
大家一起犯一样的错误
他们身上就会一起发生这些事情
就有可能你能够预测到
行情一个局部反转的位置
可以讲一下如果被断头的话
是从哪个地方先砍吗
如果是低于25%的话
就是整个仓位
全部账户整个报刊砍掉这样子
然后就是
我刚好这个问题也是
前几天我问营业员的问题这样
所以刚好举这个例子
然后要非常了解游戏规则
不知道就打电话问营业员
好不好
就是这个
就是有些人会害羞
不敢打电话给营业员
但其实我们本来就有支付手续费
就是
就是这个本来就是营业员服务的一环
而且有一些券商的营业员服务也是非常好的
这些券商
他的营业员就是不厌其烦的回答你的问题
服务又周到
行情又一把抓
对不对
那像这种券商呢
这种券商呢
就很适合开户
我也没讲是什么券商
所以也没有违反这个
这个讲座的原则
对不对
有一些法规的
那就是
所以我们要找一些好的券商
开户
那这样的话
就可以增加你的这个营业的这个业绩
让你更了解交易规则
非常重要
还是再三的提醒大家
讲座的位置
好
这个
再来就是每次交易规则的变动都要很清楚
就是
就是每一次交易规则的变动都有可能会让那些不知道要因为交易规则变动而修正自己策略的人继续的做错误的决定
或者是能够被你吃豆腐支付你价值
那就是然后你也要想交易规则这个变动可以让你获得什么新的资讯
可以让你利用什么新的漏洞
然后或者是这个商品跟商品之间
其实因为到现在的市场有非常多的衍生性商品
所以各式各样的商品之间都可以有一定程度的联动
那像我抓八月跟七月的价差联动
那可能上一次我是抓这个期货跟这个现货之间的价差联动的套利
那或者是同族群商品之间的价差联动套利
这些就是你都是可以去思考这么多的衍生性商品之间
是不是有这个一多一空的这个对锁价差的一些套利空间
那如果能够抓到这样的套利
基本上都是超低风险超高报酬的策略
因为基本上它就是它的多空是平衡的
所以不会因为行情的涨跌而让你承受到波动的损失
就是承受到的损失都是一些
例如说不符合你预测的情况
或市场的不理性的程度超乎你的预期
让价格的错误变得更错误
那当然这个也这个会是你要蒙受的损失
但是通常这个市场都是还是会往把价格用背一堆程式
或者是一些东西套利修正回来的这个方向移动
好
人其实不知道怎么衡量价值
这个投影片放在很后面
我们来讲一个啤酒的故事
好 已经讲过了
这个
好 没关系我们回上一页
我们就是要讲一个人其实不知道怎么衡量价值的另一个故事
就是这个
例如说
在
诶 我上次有没有讲这个故事
诶 我上次讲座的人
我有讲台风天去听演唱会的故事吗
有
有是不是
好 那就讲过了
好 那就再往下吧
好 然后就是
就是
那上次我讲过红酒的故事嘛
就是有一个
就是教授他
他
他愿意在这个一个聚会的场合
开出他的那一瓶名贵的这个
放了三十年的这个三万块的一瓶红酒
但是呢
他是绝对不愿意
这个
花两万块去买这一瓶红酒
就是这一瓶红酒
在市场上要卖的话
可能可以就是卖两万块
但是他一定不愿意
用两万块去买这一瓶红酒
但是他愿意把自己的这一瓶红酒
开了喝掉
那这个是一个听起来
其实还算合理的故事
但其实是一个不理性的选择
因为如果他觉得喝掉这一瓶红酒的价值
是高于两万块的话
他才会喝
那如果他认为喝这个红酒的价值
高于两万块的话
他就会愿意去买一瓶两万块的一样的红酒
那跟他一开始
这瓶红酒是一万块买的
放了三十年
变两万块是没有关联的
就是跟他的沉默成本
显然没有关系
人会衡量成本
人会衡量沉默成本
但是传统经济学认为人不会衡量沉默成本
所以他买这瓶一万的酒变成两万了
他要么是会喝他也愿意花两万块买
不然就是他不愿意喝他
会花两万块在市场上把这瓶酒给卖掉
那这个也是人不知道怎么衡量东西的价值嘛
就是他不是去衡量这瓶酒
是超过两万还是低于两万
来决定要不要喝跟要不要买
有可能人是因为交易成本
所以他就放弃这件事情
哦对对对对
就是这个就是也有交易成本的问题嘛
但是如果我们简化问题
就是说这个就是两万块的酒
可能他的交易成本就在几百块
可能也影响不大
但是确实你买跟卖
确实可能会有一些一点点的摩擦成本
好这个反正讲座还有十分钟
大家有什么想讲都可以畅所欲言
有吗没有好啊那我再讲最后一个
这个这个今天讲座一个很重要的知识点
希望大家可以认真听
就是自动停损停利单的好处
就是如果就是很多人会想说
我要怎么样克制自己在这个行情走到停损的时候
就停损那当然就是用出价单停损
那其实本来就不应该手动停损
因为行情有时候往反方向的发动
是直接发动一根超级长的K棒
例如说国安基金突然进场
然后你去尿个尿
回来发现怎么涨三百点了
然后你的空单直接被嘎到天上去
那就是这是非常有可能的发生事
而且你根本没办法预期七点的时候
国安基金会突然进场
你只是去尿个尿而已
你想说待会我手动停损
这个尿完尿回来发现你账户的钱已经归零了
这个也不会归零归25%了
这个也是有可能发生的嘛
好那所以这个
下一页是
好就是使用出价单让交易机械化
就是我在之前youtube影片也有讲过
就是你按的顺序是你按进场
然后马上去按挂上停损的
NIT就是market if touched
就是出价单
然后再去慢慢的挂你的停力
你的停力
爱挂不挂也都没有关系
快到再挂也没关系
就是因为台子棋没有排队的问题啦
所以你很满挂也没关系
如果是古棋的话
就是买入然后马上挂停损
然后马上去挂停力
这个顺序是这样
就是因为有时候你往上滑
去挂停力的时候
你下面就反方向去喷停损
喷过你的停损了嘛
好所以就是进场的第一件事情
先挂停损单
请问一下台子棋没有排队的问题
所以交易的顺序不是
就是全部的交易都有排队的问题
都是先挂的先成交
只是因为台子棋的这个
200跟100之间是分100个TIC
所以大家的挂单被分的很散
所以排队的问题还好
就是出价未成的情况
不会很常发生
但是如果你是打股票期货
或是现股的话
出价未成的情况
就会非常非常常发生
如果那个地方挂了500张的话
那你后排就要那500张都成交
之后才换你成交
但如果你很早就挂了
甚至是你盘前就已经预挂的话
那你在那500张里面的排队
所以可能就是可能前20张
或是甚至超级前面
如果你盘前就已经预挂了
好所以就是还是要排队
只是台子棋不太需要排队
就是它的排队都很短嘛
因为被切的TIC是非常非常细的
好所以进场第一件事
就是挂上出价停损单
然后我讲的是真的
就是很多券商的APP是没有出价停损的功能
就是真的不知道在干嘛
就是如果你的券商的下单软体
是没有出价功能的话
那你就应该要换成一家有出价停损功能的券商
什么券商有出价停损的功能呢
大家要自己上网研究研究
好这个是最后一个知识点
好然后居然还有一个知识点
就是心理账户任业损失
就是很多人都会觉得未平仓损益
就是还没有亏的钱
然后或者是那个就是股票的那个清单
因为我会问别人说
你今年的具体赚赔是多少钱
他说今年喔
今年小赚三万块
只是账户APP里面是负三百万
他还觉得自己小赚三万呢
太猛了吧
因为台积电是好公司啊
之后会涨回来啊
我这个台积电亏三百万
就是钱先放在台积电
我支持好公司嘛
这个总有一天涨回我的六百块以上的
对不对
这个所以不是你心理认裂了那个损失
你才蒙受损失
也不是你平仓了才损失
就是不管那个未实现损益
不是说他就是没发生啊
不是还没发生
他已经发生了
未实现损益
就是已经发生的损益
只是他的名字
不知道为什么是未实现
因为他还没有被认裂而已
就是这个是大家一定要知道的
因为真的非常非常多人
他的回答都是把
把已经这个
就是已经结算的损益
跟分开结算的损益
分开算
这个是非常荒谬的一件事情
就是
这是完全一样的
就是已经发生的未平仓损益
就是已经发生的
权益数的坚损
好
end
谢谢大家